alright guys in this video today we will
be listing for you what we consider the
biggest 15 trevor henderson creatures
and monsters i will be listing their
dimensions and main abilities as well as
this is a long list i will straight away
start with the smallest in this ranking
but rest assured even the smallest is
still pretty big
on the number 15 spot we have the milk
water ambassador which measures 40 feet
or 12.1 meters it weighs close to 55
tons which is still a huge size for a
creature place at the bottom of this
list this member of the cryptid species
has a very humanoid-like appearance with
brown legs and white head however it
does not have a torso to go with the
rest of its limbs this creature is
supposed to be able to manipulate
technology as well
at number 14 we have the giant puppeteer
which stands at a height of 100 feet or
30.48 meters there is nothing sweet
about this 32 ton enormous skinny light
blue giant its head is bird-like but its
body has no feathers
this gone looking creature has very
sharp talons and is depicted as
controlling a human puppet body with
strings it can cause great destruction
and trap other people via the human
puppet it carries with it
next at 13
we have the overlooker of black watcher
it is a giant measuring 125 feet in
height and weighs 105 tons the most
distinctive feature of this creature is
its two bright yellowish eyes which can
be visible during the night while its
true form is a mystery apart from being
able to raise down human settlements
with ease the overlooker is supposed to
have the night vision abilities as well
as sending messages to other members of
its kind through some unknown means
at 12 we have the web kraken which
stands at 177 feet or 54 meters this
gargantuan reddish type of arachnid
looking creature also weighs in around 6
000 tons this creature can certainly
more than measure up against the kraken
in greek mythology humans are easy meals
for this monster if it feels like having
one while it's true abilities remain
unknown there is speculation that can
like a spider emit some kind of
dangerous substance when the need arises
on the 11th spot we have the watchtower
this furry giant possesses the furry and
mobility of a chewbacca but not the
ladder's small stature instead it is 656
feet or 200 meters long however there
are no reliable estimates as to its
actual weight this quarter bit is
covered with hair or fur it stands as a
mask and defender of a small unknown
town hence it differs from the other
giants on this list since her strength
is used more for defensive rather than
offensive purposes
at number 10 we get the slit down the
clouds it is a member of the infamous
group of creatures known as the giants
this one in particular has many
similarities to other existing giants
which may imply that they are related
the slit down the clouds depicts a
spider-like creature that is incredibly
large the giant has 13 legs and it looks
slender and sharp like sharpened bamboo
poles
there are four tentacles in the middle
of the 13 legs because its entire body
is hidden in the fog we cannot see a
specific appearance but we do know that
it is around a thousand feet tall
number nine goes to the tree head which
is a 1 000 feet tall or 304 meters tall
monster and weighs in an excess of a
hundred thousand tons this brown
humanoid giant is famous for its
gargantuan head which appears to be a
collection of much smaller heads with
long hair apart from the great strength
this creature possesses great visual
equity and can zero in on tiny humans
with ease even if they are at a
significant distance
further for a giant of this size it is
very agile nimble and stealthy as well
on the number eight spot we have the
giant with red dots while it is not as
big as the planet jupiter itself which
also has a red dot its height of 1500
feet or 457 meters and a weight of close
to 500 tons is still more than
impressive this humanoid giant is
depicted as having a black body with red
dots that seem to glow apart from
causing great destruction there is the
belief that the glowing red dots may
shoot some kind of energy field when it
attacks its enemies
so on the seventh spot is the precursor
of the first war who is 800 meters tall
but for whose weight we have no reliable
estimates he is one of the first giants
to walk the earth and also the first to
start a war between them and humans
besides its obvious strength due to its
size
this creature also possesses great speed
this and other giants like him are so
powerful that if they work together they
can succeed against whatever humans
throw at them basically they can
annihilate the world itself
at number six we have the bird watcher
which is 1.5 kilometers high or
basically a mile its weight is unknown
this bipedal giant also has many eyes to
go with its humanoid body
hence it also has supervision and people
have speculated that apart from spotting
objects at great distances it also uses
its vision to scan for humans worthy of
being ascended to the heavens for
salvation it may also possess some kind
of telephonic ability
to communicate with other giants and
even summon other birds
so we come to the top 5 and at number 5
is 2027 who is one third of the trio
named the mystic guess 2027 is 1.65
kilometers long and weighs around 8 000
tons
since this creature is depicted as
standing in a foggy environment we do
not know its actual color but some
presumed it to be gray
this six-legged and very rangy giant has
the potential for causing great havoc
and can either grab people easily or
swing its limbs to trash them to their
deaths
from afar it seems to have some kind of
protrusions on its back which may or may
not be a defensive mechanism
at number four is the sky tentacles well
the sky tentacles is a gigantic creature
made by trevor henderson obviously not
much is known about the formidable bees
obviously it is an extraterrestrial
monster or maybe an extra dimensional
one reaching its tentacles through the
wormhole while the rest of its body is
unknown or stuck inside the other
dimension it is depicted as four large
jet black tentacles coming out from what
appears to be a riff in the sky the
tentacles themselves are of varying
lengths and resemble the legs of a
spider specifically a tarantula due to
having many dark hairs or possibly
spikes covering them the sky in the
image is red purple in color and where
there appears to be a cloud-like object
from which your creature and multiple
jolts of lightning are protruding out
from
starting our top 3 we have the wandering
faith whose height is 5 kilometers and a
length of 8.5 kilometers and the weight
is 1.7
billion tons billion with a b
this grey quarter bit creature is
somewhat reminiscent of an ancient
dinosaur in shape though there is no
comparison as to who is the bigger one
here super strength aside this
mysterious creature has as its duty the
task of ascending humans it finds worthy
to heaven and does this by grabbing them
with its tendrils and raising them up
cheers
so the second position goes to the misty
giant which is similar in proportion to
that of the wandering faith it is
depicted to be walking towering over
humans while the entire area is covered
in a fog and hence it is also known as
the fog walker this is the type of
creature that you would imagine in a
story like stephen king's demis its main
purpose is to infect people the misty
giant is roughly five kilometers or
three miles tall
finally at the number one spot we have
the behemoth as its name suggests this
is more than a gargantuan monster
it is the size of a satellite orbiting a
planet it is 300 kilometers in height
and 600 kilometers in length while its
weight is unknown we can see why this
creature is named this way the behemoth
can send tremors through the earth and
mountains are like legos which it can
break through with ease along with its
sheer size and strength its back is
protected with hardened scales this
means that our current weapons will not
be even enough to make it scratch its
back
so there you have it guys the top 15
biggest trevor henderson giants hope you
have enjoyed watching this video because
we have come to the end of it so do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe as well to be a part of the
mind cube family but most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates or
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam